welcome to the presentation on units
let's get started so if i were to tell
you let me make sure my pen is set up
right if i were to tell you that someone
is
let's say they're driving at a speed
let's say it's zach
where's my pen go oh i'm using the wrong
tool
okay so let's say i had zach
and they're driving at a speed of
let me say
28
feet
feet
per minute
so what i'm going to ask you is
if he's going 28 feet in every minute
how many
inches
will zach travel
in one second so how many inches per
second is he going to be going
let's try to figure this one out
so let's say if i had 28
and i'll write ft short for feet feet
per minute and i'll write min short for
minutes
so 28 feet per minute let's first figure
out how many inches per minute that is
well we know that there are
12
inches
per foot
right
and if you didn't know that you do now
so we know that there are 12 inches per
foot
so if he's going 28 feet per minute he's
going to be going 12 times that many
inches
per minute
so
12 times 28 let's see let me do the
little work down here 28 times 12
well 16
56
and then 280. i probably shouldn't be
doing this messy and this kind of stuff
it's it it'd be okay to use a calculator
although it's always good to do the math
yourself it's good practice so that's 6
5 8 is
13
336.
so that equals 336
inches
per minute
and something interesting happened here
is that you notice that i had a foot in
the numerator here and i had a foot in
the denominator here so you can actually
treat units just the same way that you
would treat actual numbers or variables
that you have the same number in the
numerator and you have the same number
and denominator and you're multiplying
not adding you can cancel them out so
the feet and the feet canceled out and
that's why we were left with inches per
minute
i could have also written this as
336
foot
per minute
times
inches that's inches
inches per foot
and and because the foot per minute came
from here and inches per foot came from
here
and then
i would cancel this out and i would have
gotten inches per minute so anyway i
don't want to confuse you too much with
all of that unit cancellation stuff the
bottom line is you just remember well if
i'm going 28 feet per minute i'm going
to go 12 times that many inches per
minute right because they're 12 inches
per foot
so i'm going 36 336
inches per minute
so now i have the question but we're not
done because the question is how many
inches am i going to be traveling in
in one second so let me erase some of
this stuff here at the bottom
let me erase this because that's just
probably just going to confuse everybody
actually erase this too
okay
so i'm going to be going
so 336
336
inches
let's write like that
inches per minute
and i want to know how many inches per
second
well what do we know
we know that
one minute
and notice i write it in the numerator
here because i want to cancel it out
with this minute here
one minute is equal to how many seconds
it equals
60 seconds
right and and just this this part can be
confusing but it it is always good to
just take a step back and think about
what i'm doing if i'm going to be going
336
inches
per minute
how many inches am i going to travel in
one second am i going to travel more
than 336 or am i going to travel less
than 336 inches per second well
obviously less because the second is a
much shorter period of time so if i'm in
a much shorter period of time i'm going
to be traveling a much shorter distance
if i'm if i'm going the same speed so i
should be dividing by a number which
makes sense i'm going to be dividing by
60. and i know this can be very
confusing the beginning but that's why i
always want you to think about should i
be should i be getting a larger number
or should i be getting a smaller number
and that'll always give you a good
reality check
and if you just want to look at how it
turns out in terms of units
we know from the problem that we want
this minutes to cancel out with
something and get into seconds so if we
have a minutes in the denominator in the
units here we want a minutes in the
numerator here and a seconds in the
denominator here and one minute is equal
to 60 seconds
so here once again the minutes and the
minutes cancel out and we get 336
over 60
inches
per second
and
excuse me
and now if i were to actually divide
this out
we could see actually we could just
divide the numerator and the denominator
by six
six goes into 336 what 56 times
56
over 10
and lo we could divide that again by two
so then that gets us 28 over five
and 28 over 5 let's see 5
goes into
28
5 times
25
3
5.6
so this equals 5.6
so we i think we now just solve the
problem
if zach is going 28 feet in every minute
that's his speed he's actually going 5.6
inches
per second
hopefully that kind of made sense let's
try to see if we could do another one
if i'm going
91
feet
per second
how many miles per hour is that
well
91 feet
per second
so how many if we want to say how many
miles that is should we be dividing or
should we be multiplying well we should
be dividing because it's going to be a
smaller number of miles and we know that
there that
one mile
is equal to and you might want to just
memorize this
5280 feet is actually a pretty useful
number to know
and then that will actually cancel out
the feet
and then we want to go from seconds to
hours
right
so if we go from seconds to hours if i
can travel 91 feet per second how many
will i travel in an hour i'm going to be
getting a larger number because an hour
is a much larger period of time than a
second and how many seconds are there in
an hour well there are 3 600 seconds in
an hour 60 minutes 60 seconds per minute
and 60
minutes per hour so 3 600 over 1
seconds
per hour
and these seconds will cancel out
and then we're just left with we just
multiply everything out
we get
in the numerator
91
times
36
right 91 times 1 times 3600
in the denominator we just have 5280.
and this time around i'm actually going
to
use a calculator let me bring up the
calculator just to show you that i'm
using a calculator
let's see
so if i say 91
times
3600 whoops missed up
one
times thirty six
hundred that equals a huge number
divided by five thousand two hundred and
eighty
oh man i keep messing up
91 times 3600
divided by 5200
this calcula i think my mouse is messed
up let me see if i can type it 91
times 3600
divided by 5280
62.05
so that equals
62.05
miles
per hour